what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i was on the show on netflix and i got
fired for a joke because there was an
international like competition and the
chinese team was competing and they fell
off the obstacle course into the water
and they called it the beast blood and i
didn't say that the competitor's name
was bin fung yeah and i said there goes
bin fung into the duck sauce
[Laughter]
and the hypocrisy was i got fired
whatever before that for that i got
fired
but bin fung bin fung retweeted the the
clip of me saying that bin fung who i
said it about was very obvious like
hilarious it's so funny whatever you
want to come to my comic shows but i got
fired by this fat white woman named
barbara yeah because barbara has to
[ __ ] stand up for china when it's
like you're fat [ __ ] you have dark souls
on your fingertips
[Laughter]
children who have down syndrome
beautiful population of children to work
with they one of the things with down
syndrome is yes bigger bigger tongues
from the chromosomal deficiencies you're
saying that you have
my mother when she was
nine years old
she she grew up in the korean war she
was walking her sisters to school just
cut to the chase her sister got hit by a
military truck
entrails on the streets there was no
ambulance so she had to run up and get
her my uncles right they took rice bags
picked up my aunt who'd obviously died
finally we have some meat yeah yeah
i'm trying it yeah it's fine
it's my mom's trauma don't do that
that's the most worse thing about it i
know i didn't take my shoes and socks
off is that okay might be disrespectful
to the sun god
i don't want to be disrespectful
[ __ ]
legally that's down syndrome tongue a
dst wow and i'm not offended by it thank
you for validating mine say it again dst
down syndrome thank you you're welcome
absolutely so
what else is don syndrome about me
they're typically uh usually because of
the chromosomal abnormality a bit
overweight
um
on the smaller side
you usually lifespan is to about 60.
um
[Laughter]
and uh and instigate the instigators
they're
they're all instigators no i'm kidding
no the last part i'm kidding but but you
do you do have uh a lot of but no
qualities okay okay
please
there's a comedy line
and you were right again right but
that's what good communities i
understand but then you had crossed over
which which particularly [ __ ] pissed
me off which part questions don't have
down syndrome
okay
no no no i've never done a dna test yeah
no i almost positive i'm almost positive
i don't have it okay i have it
no i can drive
i can drive okay yeah i know when i
watch i know how to stream things on you
know who can they do that
yes oh they can some of them can because
they have good therapy yeah yeah yeah
can they can they um
do you have a pretty good kd on when
they play warzone on uh
yeah i mean one i was yeah we had a
really high functioning short neck small
ears okay there you go
latin face of course but that's because
i'm asian that's not fair yeah
i'm in shape
yeah yeah right almond shade that's not
fair are they just describing asians
what the [ __ ] a short neck oh
no but bobby it's a compliment because
it's uh you know uh working with all
types of children with disabilities down
syndrome children you know children with
down syndrome are
friendly no the friendliest children
just truly out of out of the uh you know
and that's also a characteristic of
children with downstream is they're very
friendly and outgoing you're very
friendly and outgoing and you you know
and that's and that's what it is so so i
i would say this bobby let me say this
as a clinical as a clinical therapist
you're talking i'm actually you know
it's silly but i i am i am technically
at least in the state of new york
legally not saying what i'm saying is
you don't have down syndrome but you
have many characteristics that are and
i'm fine with that consistent with down
syndrome and i'm fine with that i would
say you're consistent with downtown
talk about sabotage
he's on stage
and i'm in the lobby of this you know
when you open you go to lobby to get a
drink and this is like in
the late 90s
and
these two
[Music]
college girls were like
we
we don't like paulie without your
hilarious
and i go oh thank you you know
and they go
you want a [ __ ]
just like that yeah i go oh thank you
all right
so there was like paulie had a limo
there right some limo driver was going
to drive him around after the show so i
let's go i asked the limiter can mean
these girls go to limo right we're
giving a [ __ ] and then the door opens
and it's paulie oh boy and he goes what
about me dude
that's what he says
right so that he grabs both of them
and they walk
to the tour bus because we were on a
tour bus
so now i'm sitting in the limo with my
pp out
just you know the rage yeah would you be
angry yeah i thought when you said what
about me dude you pushed them to the
side and started blowing him
up you look mexican i thought you were
mexican that's what happened yeah but
but you're born in how dare you man but
in defense
what have i
i mean ten out of ten people would think
you were mexican
yeah
yeah
but i was mexican in high school yeah i
didn't the filipinos didn't like me and
my school is predominantly black and
mexican so the mexicans took me in and i
speak spanish
and i get on mexicans are i'm not even
gonna lie to you even over filipinos my
favorite people in the world yeah no
right they're my favorite people too as
long as they're citizens
i don't learn new things very easy as
you you know right
well it's
consistent with down syndrome he does
have a real um learning don't have it
bobby
yeah but chris he's he's ld he's he has
a learning disability i don't have a
learning disability i'm fine i work with
children
stop putting it out there do you have
dyslexia or nothing disability she also
has adult adhd okay i don't have an
adult nothing man i'm a normal guy i
don't know they're all like legitimate
diagnoses we'll help you i can help you
i don't need help [ __ ] you mitchie said
to me years ago and she said you know
it's a sin to support mediocrity
it's a sin merch merch merch synthetic
mediocrity right and it's like if we do
a disservice
to comedy if we don't say anything
right
so who do you want to say into the
cameras that's mediocre you quit
this is what the whole thing is you
i saw this one guy yelling on twitter
about what's going to happen if the
supreme court justice sways this way and
all and like you're just regurgitating
articles you [ __ ] googled and his
thing is he works for fedex it's like go
[ __ ] deliver the packages baby let's
deliver the packaging just mail me my
[ __ ] okay take a seat hun yeah let the
people who we voted in just do their
jobs and trust in the system and that's
it yeah that's how hitler came to power
don't ask questions
when i first hooked up with kalila first
of all she's hot and went gorgeous yeah
and when she i i i did this i've never
done this before when i saw her naked i
got on my hands and knees with a t one
tear coming down my eye
right and i i and my lips are trembling
like this like this right can i go ahead
i don't even believe in him but i go
thank you jesus like i was
that's how he plays i was once i was
crying i was convul i was shaking right
yeah and then when we [ __ ] we're like
that's my style
tit for tat you know what i mean pull in
and out you know what i mean i like all
that stuff right before her i'm not
gonna say her name but i made love to a
woman i [ __ ] a woman
made love to a woman and she did the
hula hoop
oh i told you about that right yeah so
she doesn't go up and down when she's on
top she does you know me she
right right and you know my dick
doesn't do that
right so i was just like whoa this feels
it felt like it was going to rip rip rip
right and and then i try to go hey can
you do up and down she's like i don't
know i don't know and she kept doing the
and that's when i knew i go this is
never gonna work she's hot she's cool
you know i mean that that could have
been a teachable moment no she does she
can't learn it if you don't know up and
down
if you don't know up and down at the age
of 30.
you're out you're there's no way you'll
ever learn it yeah yeah i don't know
what to say sorry sorry go ahead sorry i
don't know
i'm gonna say this okay cuz you always
look like you're sneezing
[Laughter]
that's funny
hey man you watch it very good very
funny amazing very funny it's a [ __ ]
up disease and i'm not making fun of the
disease
your body it's a crazy disease it's like
your body just
[Music]
succeeding them or making fun of them
right but they'll just be like
[Laughter]
we just have to find the middle ground
here right i think that's what we're
going to get to yes right the middle
ground eventually yeah because you know
it's like i know a lot of white dudes
who are angry who are actors and they
complain to me all the f you know it's
all minorities now it's a [ __ ] for 50
years 60 years in this business we
couldn't even [ __ ]
genghis khan john wayne
that's john wayne yeah yeah
you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and that's what
john wayne sells tickets that's the
difference
you know and you could pronounce his
name yeah yeah yeah yeah imagine the
asian actors who auditioned for that
part i found out who got it oh my god
yeah who got it
i've never had anal i've never received
anal sex and i've never given anal sex
ever in my life and i've never actually
uh had a woman even touch my butthole
it's something in i guess in maybe the
neighborhood i'm from we don't do the
butt stuff so as far as the butt tickle
yeah i don't know how to you know maybe
you could do maybe take one of the coven
nasal swab things and you do that
you do an asian cove attack yeah you
know i'm playing irvine this weekend
i'll sell out thank you but it'll you
know
i'll crush it absolutely the whole
audience will be sitting on the floor
indian style but what can you
do no they do they they do this right
they do this like this and they smoke
like that
they're they're machetes you know what i
feel like you don't have a butthole that
even smells like i would imagine like
you pull it out and it's like a you know
it's like smelling the inside of a
i beg to differ
really yeah yeah you don't look like a
stinky because koreans usually don't
stick and they don't sweat
i don't know what about the sweating
stuff yeah but i [ __ ] good
and i've learned and it's stinky i have
leaky you have leaky it's my because
they used to call my and this is not a
lie and george's gonna test it because
i've talked about this before they used
to call my dad the korean kite
and the reason why they call him the
korean kite was because my dad would
either get drunk or even not get drunk
and be completely naked in a rage
in the house and he would be naked just
either beating up my mom or slamming the
keyboards on my brother's head which he
did once
this casio keyboard right
and and
whenever he would come in and we'd be
with friends we'd be scared but then as
you i i would tell my friend i go wait
for it and when he turned around
you'd see a long white toilet paper
sticking out of his [ __ ] nice right
and i go there it is the korean kite and
they'd be like oh it's real it's legend
but it's a real discovery right and so
it's like and then i thought why would
and then as an older adult i realized i
have tissue in my butthole
because we just have leaky butts yeah i
mean so my [ __ ]
it's just just wet
and there's just [ __ ] on it mild
incontinence yeah my like okay but i but
i i
i wouldn't i'm sorry for that story i
mean you know like i think it was long
but i apologize yeah i could have said
no one just like andre's nice sweet face
like i would think his [ __ ] is a
nightmare cause it's just how sweet and
innocent he looks oh right right brutal
yeah bleeding as anal fissures but look
at his smile right now you stick his
finger and he smiles like that you don't
like it that's got a scar for you for
life yeah i would think what's going to
make it sound
[Music]
the mainstream is going the woke route
and they're doing that because like
chris said it supports a whole
infrastructure [ __ ] it's like if i'm
going to review a comedy special
my if i need purpose as a writer i got
to review a bad one and tell you it was
good and that's where i find purpose
because if i'm telling you a good one
was good i have no purpose because you
already know that because you [ __ ]
laugh and that's why
that's why i mean reviewing comedy
specials is hilarious it's like guy we
know yeah it's we review it in real time
by laughing or not yeah yeah yeah i knew
i knew that that comedy special sucked
because i used to put my daughter to
sleep yeah that's okay that's why i know
it sucked it was a [ __ ] and that's
why you guys give themselves meaning by
going this is look it wasn't exactly
funny but here's why it was needed yeah
special right now
that's why you honestly such a [ __ ]
genius that's why you're on such a
genius because don't say that you're
gonna get kissed i'll kiss you right on
the [ __ ] dirty greek mouth um so he
said because what he says what he's what
we [ __ ] have done now he's like you
know what these [ __ ] you know
these magazines want to lie and say this
person got the number one concert or go
see these comedy specials and then
[ __ ] lie because it's an hour-long
snooze fest then guess what we do yana
sits in his bathtub and he writes
articles from the new york times yeah we
just from the new yorker and we fake
them bill bill burr called me up he goes
guys congratulations on the new yorker
tell him and i went yeah i went i wrote
that i wrote that yeah he wrote it
giannis from his [ __ ] bathtub i'm
just as american as anybody that lives
in this country
when was your first kiss
[Laughter]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you